[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
foreign
there I'm gonna have to set this stream
deck up you know what's funny is I can't
pick it up but I gotta stream deck I
need to set that up
because I plan on stream memo for you
guys man I do enjoy streaming
um as you can see in the background some
OverWatch too uh now as far as the other
Lords now they should be
did I wow
did I really mute myself again
only game sound
all right all right you should be able
to hear me now
should be able to hear me now
please let hear me now it is so
embarrassing that you guys can't hear me
that you guys couldn't hear me
but you should be able to hear me now I
should be loud and clear crispy clear
all right so let me repeat what I was
gonna say again
okay so I am currently waiting for
people coming here Kitt Smith will be
playing with us tonight now as far as
the other Lords I did send them a
message
I am uh waiting on response to see if
any of them want to jump in here so
that's up in the air currently but you
know
oh you can't read the game also
smooth should be on the the game he's
just not talking right now
uh so
what we're going to do is we're going to
play a little bit of this man some
OverWatch uh you know uh we will be
present tomorrow for some grounded the
Lords will be there
uh tonight's probably just going to be
me and some uh some friends of the realm
now keep in mind uh any of you want to
jump in definitely you know tell me
I can hear everything what do you mean
everything
I'm curious what you mean everything
do I I turned down the audio clip man
what do you mean everything man
rsj fan you have to enlighten me what
you mean by everything
because I can't hear nothing but what's
outside these heads but what's inside
this headset
it's a black lightning 100 what's up man
audio is good you mean the game oh okay
just so I can show you guys can hear me
fine
you know um who's heard stuff about this
game
so do you guys like it like this
or like this right now until I start
playing the game how do you guys feel
about this View
until I actually start playing the game
how you guys feel about this view until
I actually start playing the game
I'm experimenting man I'm experimenting
experimenting with this this streamy
thing I'm not a streamer you know I'm a
podcaster not a streamer
foreign
Mack
um it seems like the stream uh the
servers are a little bit better now we
will have room for two currently so if
you guys want to jump in here
uh I'll send you a party invite will
play
uh kid smooth will be jumping on here
soon
kiss me you almost ready
oh you're you're waiting for me I
thought she was a foreign
talking to the chat waiting for you to
be done
so right now Mega it's me and kid smooth
you know maybe we'll get two two of you
guys in here this game improved
now
this is a warning
kids routine seems to rage he might last
two games maybe three maybe maybe he'll
even last one game
because smooth is very he's a wild card
with stuff like that this man might only
last one game and he out because that's
just how smooth it is
so you know
do warning you
he rages
there'll probably be some cussing from
this man
warning
adult audience pm
service to be available again at 7 pm
Pacific time so that's second that
anyway
all right what was he saying
oh I was reading the um
your service thing
all right what do they want me to use
this code for
what code
what's code
Battlenet
yeah you just uh got to make a quick uh
account it doesn't take long can you
guys hear smooth fine I'm curious if you
guys can hear smooth fun
oh my battle.net
you should be able to hear him five
I need a mixer that's what I need I need
a mixer like a big mixer
so I can control all the chats
so you know people people talking extra
I can just mute them I can just mute
them I don't have to listen to them
all right all right just making sure I
want to just let me connect with my Xbox
account they will you won't have
anything like
as far as like cosmetics and stuff I
don't think you played too much of this
game anyway they even have Cosmetics
like that uh they have to do a merger
and that takes like I don't know it
might do this game has had like a
catastrophe
couple hours it's kind of ridiculous I
mean a couple days
but I logged in two times instantly two
times instantly so I think we're good I
think we're good
foreign
so I guess we could look over the battle
pass while we wait for smooth to do the
thing
okay
what's up
yeah
foreign
yeah I don't know why it keeps muting
all right so we we got the the diva
Mech
looked pretty good pretty good uh
okay what about this is the one I liked
got the Twilight one
some crazy looking ones
how much is the battle pass I believe 10
bucks is the battle pass I believe 10
bucks but uh I got the one that gives it
uh pretty much all the seasons
I think I don't know I got the Forty
dollar one
but I do think the just just the season
passes 10.
all right so we got the little payload
thing
uh I didn't get a place echo echo came
in like late OverWatch one I didn't get
a place Echo
the lunar Skins are sick who which one's
lunar hold up
oh Lou uh is this the person you're
talking about
did I do something [ __ ] wrong like
come on man
I forgot to put the um
I didn't utilize the code that came up
on my freaking screen bro
all right so I was too busy
how do I get this thing to
recognize the account that I have
I don't know man I I I put the what I
did was put the screen in you you just
have to like merge the account you don't
have to merge the account right now
and I'm a merge it because I ain't got
time for this [ __ ] oh that one looks
nice
I like that
yo
that's that's a nice skin that's a nice
skin so that's where they get us people
man
oh they change the sound effects of her
abilities they should let you hear that
here's Genji
I got a lot of Genji skins
what are you gonna paint munchkin
got a lot of Genji skins but we're
trying to paint one I'm not sure
Reaper skins
got a couple of those I got the Hellfire
Reaper skate how does that look chat
look at that Reaper that hellblade one
Hell Fire
okay
um what do I do join your game yeah
invite to group
here we go
now like I told you guys
this is this is not a PG iron Lords
stream man smooth rages I can't control
what he says
so he goes off the deep end
that's on him not me
don't don't go right right me out to the
other iron Lords man I can't help with
the people on my sh on my stream do
I didn't get like where do I go
ILP rated R
I thought I sent you an invite
made this all difficult for no reason
can you not play I mean I clearly you
could play with people hold on I'm about
to switch my um which I'm gonna call it
my own
I just sent you another controller
yes
oh no I have to swap my controller
actually all right all right Chad who
you want me to play with what character
do you want me to play I will play with
whatever character you guys choose
my beards Immaculate I really appreciate
that man my beard is nice it is
oh you're on stream yeah camera I gotta
streaming a little bit though I mean I
gotta trim it down a little bit
girlfriend don't like it when I don't
maintain it which you know rightfully so
so I got to do better on that man
plus the thick chick
oh you want me to use um
the the German [ __ ]
I think or she might be a Russian chick
I don't know
what is that chick's name
this chick here is this who you want me
to use
I don't know about that I'm not really
good with her I think I'm gonna struggle
with her can I pick another character
man do I really got to use this chick
I do get I didn't get any um
what I didn't get any invitation like do
I got to go to social or something
friends
kid smooth
and white group
I sent me an invite go to Social and
send me an invite
see if it pops up somewhere
what's your battle next
yeah I uh
that dish I don't know
yeah this is so stupid hold on let me go
to this icon over here
I don't even I don't even uh
not join me
see they made this stuff too complicated
for no reason
not to be getting on my nerves invite to
the Xbox Live party it's not letting me
hold on let me reset OverWatch too I'm
gonna reset over at Watch Two and get
like a 20 000 Q I'm gonna be mad
foreign
no huge cue man
no huge cue
then whatever they did
fine what
yeah so you're gonna put water in a um
all right did you get that hey
oh now yeah now it's letting me send you
more
all right here we go man
[Music]
all right you got to pick what uh what
you want to play I'm gonna play support
here must you can use this did Mommy
right how about that Australian chick
she's new
um who did I used to play as Bastion or
something like that yeah that would be
damage I believe I can't remember we're
all right press all right I'm in I don't
see anything
you have to click one of the rows
did you waiting for role click damage I
think it's damaged it should be damaged
his name is Bastion
never he was locked
no you you have to
click hold up
it's saying that you have to okay you
declined the roll again
waiting for groups starters to select
row
you accept you must select a role before
your group can queue which okay damage
okay damage
and then press X
all right there we go we going
we kill a Toronto like you're not gonna
be able to see okay I'd go in a practice
range if I was you
yes fashion is a uh damage
I'm going to play the new character on
support
find my own power
what is this
double oh I'm liking
foreign
let's put something let's put something
big let's put this chip
oh it takes a good couple shots to kill
her
oh it's still taking you to accuse
do the training bot
yeah well they're looking for a game
here come here Smith how many was that
come here I got this move I don't know
what it does come here
all right try to move in this line that
up
are you faster
uh your fell off
I mean I told you to go I didn't tell
you to fall off
I think it's supposed to make you faster
I'm not entirely sure though
prepare for battle
[Music]
you know
OverWatch is still fun man
where the hell is my batch in there
are you attacked
I thought I was supposed to be damaged
oh well who's the characters you could
pick
there's some I only got three pins
Reaper sojourn pick Reaper Reaper is
good
he's the shotgun
I'll find my own path I'll stay I'll
stick near you and keep you alive
[Music]
all right come on
behind you I got you man I'm right on
you
oh I like I like the animations they've
always been really good at how
everything looks like the presentation
of OverWatch has always been top-notch
question can I change
the
route number
no you can't okay wow oh god wow great
man I was just looking at my settings
for a second
I'm sitting here putting shotgun slugs
into your backs in the dairy bullets is
bouncing off his room but somebody just
does just stands in front of me and I go
down I don't I don't understand like the
DPS on games like this
and you can't like super Sprint or
anything up here what are you doing dude
stop it
get back get back don't go out there get
her get her jumper
I need some help
okay
he's coming on me man what did you
believe me you abandoned me
man I'm horrible with her shot
oh God
don't ever leave me like that again
watch out the ice don't get in there
well I'm stuck
oh I try
get her get her don't let her down
oh man they got me a bag today
oh that was unfortunate they weren't
liking that
done playing around
let's go
oh
again
I don't know
I didn't really care about the campaign
to be honest with you
wow oh I got him I got one I need
something that has distance bro these
shotguns I gotta be almost into your
butt cheeks just to get them down
oh my God the ice caught me
all right I think it's
okay all right I'm gonna I'm gonna
switch
I'm gonna help you out more
I'll be right behind you
wow what a little nut butt
what did you call her
all right all right here we go
person puts a rock in between
show them smooth
I can't save you over here
I don't remember how to switch to a gun
oh
all right Smith where are you
porch are you dead yeah
everyone on me
I hear that big thing here
I can't stand that movie
power engaging
get it here get you some health
gotta keep you guys alive
don't go too far
how does it take out okay
get out of there
Frozen
showed him
I'm counting on you keep me alive
[Music]
oh hey
oh
that was a good little fight man
that was a good little fight they got me
took like the whole team but they got me
you should
oh what did he kill me with
it's go time
I was in the
snacks we're about to lose
can we push it back
can we do it
we got to keep you alive
we've got to keep you alive too
shoot him Soldier
get me
get up
no sleeping on the job
push the back strong push the back
don't let them have any ground well
you're dead then I can't get you
all right here we go here we go
show them
don't be scared
why is everyone scared of me
oh
you don't have to get that close to
uh
I'm alone
I'm alone
[Music]
oh I'm dead
I'm dead
yeah me and her walls it's crazy the
person in front of me could have easily
have tooken her out and he just lettered
it yeah I think it's a wrap this time
thank you
[Music]
shoot him
nothing I can do man
maybe I should be attacked I feel like
that's that was the biggest issue I
wasn't attacked
Okay so we've got to play the game
oh
nice smooth nice
ah
can we switch gotta do damage unlocked
okay thank you
that was crazy
ah it feels like OverWatch one I'm not
gonna lie I mean is that a bad thing you
guys invite others uh yeah I can invite
people uh whoever wants to join
foreign that's that's what you did
Michaela
get one more pumpkin and draw a face or
something
I'm gonna put it on top of the neck and
I don't want that touch of anything
wash your hands first
okay
okay
all right so let me
how do I
PS3 game is group
all right so um you got to send me a
message uh Zion
I guess since this time
um
we'll play
you want to try a tank or something
I'm gonna try Gingy
you can always click uh all rolls
you see on the right lets you pick all
rows that would probably be the best
thing for you to do pick all rows
I wish we could get uh
I did I hit something wrong
oh okay hold up
all right here's man join this party
see we get this going man
oh
I need my pillow
oh you're still learning the game did
you uh is everyone here
or did that dude leave
I see three of us in a thing
uh okay well uh
hey I start
oh no he he posted me
I'm pretty sure he's in here
all right I think he's in here ready
Sketchers
all right so I guess I'm gonna play
damage this time
see how that goes
I can't remember everything about this
guy
all right let's see here
oh
damage wise I'll probably use
I don't know
uh they they consider damage and tank
maybe the same thing
because you couldn't pick Bastion right
smooth
yeah but I have to unlock them they say
he has a lock on it
oh they making you unlock him
that's crazy
better make me not unlock anybody
well I think I had enough time in the
game to like bypass all that I didn't
have to unlock anyone
yes
oh someone quote uh someone
shouted out my review on the diaper
Chronicle
yes it's bad they locked away the rest
of the heroes unless you have the battle
pad it was letting me play them on the
other one
it's kind of weird
I thought they
I thought they let you
it takes entirely too long to find a
game
for a game that just pretty much came
out
maybe it's because we're going for like
specific roles
let me just
I hit all rules
oh we're in the console pool that's why
we're in the console that's fine we're
going to stay in the console pool though
I ain't playing for no cheaters
that that I stand by that I'm not
playing with no cheers
oh found a game
oh lion Tower
he's our own Tower
all right smooth so you only have a
couple characters
that's crazy
oh you he's like one of the hardest
people to use you're sure you want to
use them really yeah spicy hard
I don't know I've never been good with
them I've always gotten destroyed with
that man I am always ready to learn
I have some flying experience
I don't like this ability that one right
there I can't stand that one
hello we will be the lightning the rise
dust storm oh Echo got those moves
Jewish we got a Winston we about to lose
I don't know why I think we're about to
lose because of this Winston
we'll see though
I'm just happy I got somebody that can
move pretty fast that Mercy's in the
back
got them got the Genji
pick me up pick me up I'm dead I I I'm
not I I can't pick you up
you dead dead now because I'm not I'm
not Mercy
we got it though we got it we got it
it's ours
okay I got the Bastion
okay got the Hanzo
watch out don't let him grab you
he's got a mercy
I need help I need I got no help
okay let's go let's go let's go
we gotta get that Mercy man
you ain't taking me out as easy
okay you finally got me yeah
I need some more DPS support
strategy can't do everything man
I'm coming man
yeah that's right
they got our little rocket chick though
unfortunately
[Music]
oh we won the first round man we did it
man somebody lost their mind well what
do they lose their mind about in office
what they lose their mind about
Sony lost their mind like years ago
want to hear a secret joke about peanut
butter I sure do
sorry can't tell you you might spread it
what
you heard that that was corny I get it
let's go
you got this smooth are you using Genji
well
all right I'm I'm using them all right
so far only two deaths
but I don't know if I got
probably
that was a bash yeah bastion's in the
back
there's a uh roadhog up here too
oh my God man
I am a Sony fan but I mostly play on the
series X I play a lot on the series X uh
you know I do have a PC a pretty
prominent PC as well and I have a
PlayStation that bulky ass PlayStation
I still just do not like the design of
the PlayStation I don't know what they
were thinking
where are they at
uh roadhog on me
tracer on me too
let's get out of there
foreign
appreciate it buddy
oh my God Tracy is hard to hit with this
move
your mom
oh we gotta keep it
Tracer get on my nerves
oh
I like this song
wait oh oh who's the better Lucia
don't give him any inch
that's how it's done
nobody won a w at the games you see that
smooth
that used to be my favorite character
oh
that was a good little play I ain't
gonna lie
I think we won that match didn't we
yes
see that's how we do it
that's how we do it
bet you you feeling real accomplished
aren't you smooth
um not really I don't know what what my
stats are
you did fine man you did pretty good
I got a
move around with all these
there we go another game found
see they eventually got the server
issues fixed it did take them a little
bit too long uh if I may add
I wonder what she does
she's a tank I wonder what kind of tank
ability she had
yeah Zeon said smooth carried us to be
honest
I thought a big dude man it's it well he
he must be built to carry us I'm six
foot four
is she threw an ax
when's Activision going through uh
probably in the next
three or four months
it's pretty much damn near past at this
point they've got a couple more areas
that they got up past but I don't see
those areas being too much of an issue
I feel like people are more concerned
about Sony's
fights than actual competition
you know I think that's that's kind of
sad people care a lot of these these
nations seem to care more about it Sony
could survive without Activision and not
whether or not it's fair competition for
the consumer that's technical
protecting us Monopoly supposed to mean
whoa
oh
thanks I do got away I wasn't feeling
that
[Music]
what's up what's up Ash
once you get back in that place to leave
me alone
man I don't like her I don't like her at
all
I'm gonna switch
I just don't like her
finally adjacent scrap uh
let's play diva
I've always appreciated
all right so we good
how to remember her moves real quick
can't copy Nintendo and Sony can't
compete with Microsoft since Microsoft's
taking gaming seriously
I would say there's some truth into that
YouTube
what uh Sony can't copy Nintendo and
ever since Microsoft started taking
gaming seriously they've been having
issues
yeah I mean the thing is is that an
aggressive Microsoft is that because
they have the pockets to actually
compete with something they say like I
said they utilize what their biggest
weapons
they really shouldn't have issues
money has always been something
Microsoft had a lot of
but they were never using it so it's
never an issue
because they weren't never allowed to
oh got one
don't let Ash out
yeah get back in there Ash
get and give you permission to leave
oh look at her
I could use some assistance
what are you doing
foreign
I don't like her
I don't like her where is she I hate
small people she
all right hair die
[Music]
oh my God I couldn't Trace her down man
Microsoft should though Sega they need a
bell out I mean Microsoft should buy
Sega they don't necessarily need Sega
but I think Sega would be very helpful
to their overall mission statements
but as far as buying Sega I don't know
if they'll do that
that's a lot of money Sega ain't cheap
Sarah Sega has not been doing the
greatest I'll give you that
they don't produce enough
oh this chick again kill Jack boys
everything
oh my I got me man they got me they had
me they had my number
they had me pretty hardcore
oh that was pretty rough that was rough
I'm gonna take the top Flame
remaining
stop we can do this we can do this
don't let them past anything else
why are they able to go into this little
area if I run away from a fight I don't
know but we can't let them win is this
chick again
I'm fighting
man I'm getting tired of her
someone get jacked
we won
should be nice to see Shin not uh since
oh she ain't got intention on Xbox
switch
um
I think that's more of a switch thing
than not an Xbox thing
[Music]
oh okay yeah it's been so long man it's
been so long
you know I I did feel that that Mercy
helping me a good amount
I don't like Cassidy
always endorse people man
always endorse people don't be a bum
endorse your your teammates you better
be endorsing them smooth
ly
now you press right but uh the right
add-on stick down you better endorse
them
acknowledged that they did good on the
team smooth
um if you want somebody to be on your
team you gotta do the my team my player
you always want to endorse people
I tried to get Jazz up in here but he
didn't respond
he's been playing it hardcore
all right let's play another another
diva
how do I change okay office
I want the office of Diva
what about the white cat no officer my
girlfriend would kill me if I was
playing the character looked like that
she would not be pleased
I need to play that tail game whatever
it's called
emote
hold down on the d-pad
she won't hear nah but I'll know man
I'll know
that won't fly I won't fly
hold this
oh thank you for the help
I need help
I need help
fully operation
oh I tried to get my super butt oh I
tried to get it back and what happened
I need these dps's to do the DPS in man
foreign
shoot down on
shoot down on him
where is my team
hey come on man
oh
you got nothing in your sights man
you got problems this is what you got
yeah get out of that get out of that
where you going
here hold this
initializing systems
yeah I'm not leaving
oh
they after me I'm no longer tank I'm
squishy
oh I'm no longer a tank I'm squishy
uh
doomfists ain't having it
oh I was doing that I was in it I was in
I don't care what it says
oh they got so lucky I was about to get
back in that thing
man we had a first second too that sucks
come on shoot him thank you
oh
what's up fam
[Music]
yeah yeah yeah
no
[Music]
oh I killed one before I could
I outrushed it man that's all I know
that's my nature it's the rush stuff
we gotta hold that smooth they get that
for like even a second it's a wrap
look at this dude
yo I got a seven player to go through
let me record that [ __ ]
I like this character though
who are you using wow I got no more
missions wow
[Music]
get him get him get him
oh I think we just lost that was a good
fight though man we fought for that
place like crazy
come on come on let me out
oh yeah they won
ah it was a good fight though
who are you using smooth oh you like
erisa whatever her name is
she got like the the uh the spear or
whatever it is now yeah yeah I caught
like
you know I know you take the time like
hit it
let it reload hit it
we need another attack
trust me
I need the help
man what the heck
these soldiers
I like to be able to Sprint when I uh
chase after someone
at least we're taking it over though
ignored all these
all this done to him
oh my God man
let me find someone else
I really liked her
she's ready to learn what's up fun
speculation what you doing man
OverWatch seems to be working
ah
okay
my skills are improving
oh I killed two of them
team having a one-on-one battle within
your face hitting them with everything
you got in your health is not even
dropping that's ridiculous
[Music]
join me
[Music]
really like that
there's one
man I'm not used to these new changes
they've made to these people
lost that first round
we lost both rounds yeah no I think we
won the first
are you playing on PC or console and
playing on console
how'd y'all FInd matches on this game I
just clicked a quick play I didn't like
pick anything like spectacular just
quickly
oh okay
we got to be better on taking out their
support then
got to be better at taking out that
support
it's been a while since I used this dude
yeah I haven't played OverWatch in a
while too but I'm willing to give it a
try fun speculation I'm willing to give
it a try again
in the work
I don't know why I love rock but
wrecking ball
oh you can only do it for a certain
amount of time now
where are they at
where are they at
they're right there they see they have a
wrecking ball
chase after me
oh my God there's no more way to get to
get away from them once they start the
the smoke is there I'm gonna try it
again though
Fashion's changed a little bit smooth
I haven't used Bastion that's our same
Bastion has changed a little bit
that could be what quicker or something
he he no longer has to be stationary
when he gets
oh
oh
get it
get it
it's time to get out of here
we go
help me where's the where's the medic
I'm with you
there you go yum yum yum yum yum yum
keep going keep going
oh Heal Me heal my ass
oh
help me
I don't even remember what his his super
does
oh okay okay okay okay I remember now
it's the mines
I'm over here but now I'm running
let me balance you out
[Applause]
oh
man I'm starting to get the hang of his
little his little jumps though get the
hang of his little jumps
Oh I thought I could climb that that's
bull
should be able to climb that my dumb ass
sit there and followed them into their
high oh
my God the patience to sit there if you
can keep around the corner hey
what's going on
showed him
don't be scared
ah
the longer she's here the less she's
selling people
there we go
give me that give me those Scrolls
so what's this this is exclusive to Xbox
I hope you're trolling
are you sir is this exclusive to Xbox
get near that I dare you
they'll probably shoot it probably don't
yeah no
all right this is getting ridiculous I
can't see any games like this
get out of here
what's up live Supremacy
yeah Corey I kind of figured you were
trolling
okay
ain't no way you thought this was
exclusive
it'd be kind of weird
all right all right all right
it's time to switch
I think uh we lost
we don't have enough like strong people
that have a trigger
but our medic was good I got I gotta I
gotta get endorse that person well I
endorse the other person I didn't really
see him much but you can get that
endorsement too
it was our medic girl yeah no uh the
lenoro
foreign
yeah the usual
you don't want um what's that place you
went to before and we got hooked on it
once it was like you went there with it
or that's further away
what's that chick shot what was it
I can't remember her oh okay
it's the Blizzard game so technically
it's an Xbox game
look they don't own them yet man
my cybernidius form came a great cost
but you asked to change they've never
they haven't changed anything about her
she's still got the same abilities
besides it's hard to Turn Down rocket
legs
three two one round one
it's gonna happen stitching Jim Ryan
snitching Jim can't stop anything yeah
but I don't I don't know if they'll do
anything with like making anything
exclusive or anything like that
thank you
oh he paid me
what he just did to me was illegal
are you okay snowball
we still got like half the team alive
over there it's not too bad
okay we're losing more and more people
yeah my frame rate Rockets the 80s right
now uh Fraser
a hoverboard
that area was tanking the damn frame
rate for me
yeah yeah yeah
I'm hurt pretty bad
they're gonna just Ramsey
get my house back
[Music]
oh
I think Jim Ryan stitching Jim is a PR
nightmare what the pr nightmare is the
fact that people like King can make that
name up
and it's genuine
what name snitching Jim Ryan
he's got like four names on IOP
she's up
yo who's hitting me okay
got him
oh somebody hit oh that's a bad taking
my
um
that Bastion literally unloaded on me
what's going on 108 what's going on
Mason what you up to we losing so far
son here's the plan do what I do listen
to what I say and don't screw this up
he's being very aggressive
don't screw this up smooth
what you think so far it's OverWatch
like I didn't expect it I guess maybe
it's because it's a sequel a lot of
people expected a different game maybe
like
um you know I feel that there is a point
where it should have been a little bit
of a different game but I was okay with
OverWatch one
and uh they haven't done a lot with
OverWatch in a while so that's why I was
just happy to be able to play OverWatch
again
coach you're gonna jump out
come here
OverWatch
yeah
well I got an achievement
and I got disconnected
oh my God
oh should not have hit me like that I
fell away I feel away
I don't feel like they should have
gotten been over to to cap me so quick
I'm a little upset with that I'm a
little upset with that
oh God you know I got it
oh you got disconnected Yeah Tuesday I
got the achievement
oh no that's what you get for getting an
achiever
I need more DPS
I'm gonna go is that game a gun before
coming to GameStop
so what
hey guys what's your what you doing
get him get him guys they're frozen
yeah
surrender
and we still gonna lose I made a play
like that and we still gonna lose
I probably are playing again miss you
talking to me are you talking to
yourself
yeah I don't want you coming in that
room
boom
you don't kill me on your turn
yeah yeah
I might or may not have just killed one
of my teammates
it's cool though it's cool
needed that help
all right we pushing we push it
get him get him
don't let this chick live
I'm still here
oh that stupid move that's gonna make
them win
get in here
I went to press the button too it didn't
matter
played that repeat it all right smooth
all right so you do me a solid came on
here and played like an hour of
OverWatch we'll play one more game do
you want to jump on ground
I I don't want to play Grande unless I
can get like a progress unless you can
what
would be like I forgot what I'm in the
area
um surrounded by spiders at the second
like lab area
and um why you go to areas surrounded by
spiders that's a better question it was
a part of a mission I needed to to try
to progress the story
oh
seems like you've got a little bit of
issues there buddy
I could definitely play in your world I
don't have a world
or anything that can help me
yeah I don't have a world but you you uh
you said you don't you don't want to
play your world
so what what I always say if you make
progress I'm kind of curious
you gotta do the object objective right
and you get like the story cuts and
um you gotta you gotta beat the game the
game can be beat it's not like art
you um he sent me an achievement
an achievement
can you send me an invitation yeah okay
as soon as I got booted for that game I
was about to go to hysterical so you
lucky I didn't find it
all right
continue
am I in your
house progression here okay
with the confirm account yep
oh
that was pretty uh
it's pretty hectic man are you in here
um no I'm not I need you to
did you get that invite
got it
oh
all right what about now
basically you should download
um
I I got the before unless it's not yeah
you should download the game Rumble
verse
download that
you're trying to get your son to to get
gameplay for you
no no no it's time to get the game I'm
playing it's all you can download it
it's OverWatch 2 is free right yeah
download OverWatch too Mason
you know you you said something about
Rumble too
much I told him to download Rumble
versus it's like a wrestling version of
uh
like it's like it's a battle royale
it's not in Game Pass you have to it's
in the Xbox store though so go okay so
press the middle button
free up space
and uninstall uncheck Halo you know what
I saw Halo
I'll install Peppa Pig you ain't playing
that I'm gonna start Crackdown because
you're not really playing that neither
and uninstall
uh down uninstall games you don't play
um uninstall go down
let's start
uh
play the rest of these games
um on this thought MLB The Show 2022.
that'll be the show
yeah why ain't you got that I don't know
why you have the Xbox one you're
watching bleach next week uh removed go
to remove Mason
probably I'll probably kick the first
couple episodes see if I really like the
vibe of the new bleach and then if I
like it I'll probably you know move on
from there watch more
right now I'm watching the uh the dragon
show whatever that's called
um I'm watching Power
uh raising Canaan watching that Weekly
that might have ended though I don't
know I don't think it did though I think
there's still more episodes
I'm also watching
I'm watching I'm already watching Naruto
with the with the with the girlfriend
that's going pretty well
I don't even know who this is
[Music]
I ain't never use this character
cyberpunk just finished that
um
I don't know
I need to I need to actually play it I
mean watch that I need to play too
I haven't really had a chance to to
watch it
um
you know right now me and the girl have
been rewa uh I've been re-watching
Naruto with her because she's never seen
it well we just
we're in the Gara and Rock Lee fight
currently uh so you know it's it's
interesting watching that show after so
many years of not watching it I'm really
enjoying the new
uh the Game of Thrones stuff I'm really
enjoying that that's a pretty good
pretty good show I do need to watch that
cyberpunk show though
get out
I don't even know what that does
oh my God
how's the drive
House of dragons
I feel well I'm officially the only one
here
I don't know what this does but I'm
putting it up
oh
yeah we changing we we ain't using her
we changed
I'm overloading
damn how do you even Lord of the Rings
is good so many I haven't watched an
episode of The Lord of the Rings yet I
need to watch it
yeah
yeah yeah
it will be okay smooth you got this
I got you fight back more than two
players a bunch of players
fight back
don't let them have an itch
he left me
oh I felt so exposed so exposed though
I love the animations for their uh
for the Scrolls that are nice
I'm getting jacked up every encounter
I'm literally all in three oh and three
come on man what you doing
oh I was about to teleport out of it
I like that though you can teleport
through walls it's pretty nice
that that Diva was all on me David was
not feeling me
watch out smooth there's a bunch of
people over there
what's up I'm I got your bags food
not for long but I got oh I'm dead I'm
dead I'm dead
I would run I'd run I think I think I
think you're gonna die there man
you know
you're not really that's a tank you're
supposed to draw attention to yourself
and keep uh everyone else alive
man
[Music]
that we need to get rid of that turret
at the top that turret is really messing
us up
what's up
Jesus in Christ jeez man people got no
chill watch out for that church
I'm sure that upsets people
oh my God
all right it's time for me to to go tank
oh it's too late
ah
play of the game yeah he did pretty good
there's a couple times where that turret
was just messing me oh couldn't do
nothing about it
look at him just keeping it alive no
wonder we couldn't shoot he was
constantly illing you
it's my last game
yeah it's kind of hard to group up with
people you can't hear either uh Zeon
it's kind of hard to have like true
teamwork when not yeah I'm gonna do one
more and let me me and smooth probably
jump on Grounded If he if he feels up to
it
probably changed the uh
the
title
my
but my kba Rachel is for oh I'm 1980
probably be my last game you know unless
smooth might not want to jump on
um grounded either so we'll have to see
seems like Smooth is scared of a bunch
of spiders on Grounded
see I would never be scared of spiders
the spiders
I told you to clean up your stuff
foreign
[Music]
I really liked her
let me play sorry it's been a long time
since I played dessert installed this
under your name or money come on
no like okay
nobody just scared of no smoke no no
spiders yes
for hit get free
cannot mend
we I ain't gonna even hear that
and now
you gotta destroy the rails man it's the
law
you know actually we've been playing
every game we haven't been in a queue
have we smooth
one that again I said we've been playing
every game we haven't been in a queue
yeah yeah
oh
Mason I can't help you right now you're
either gonna press a
[Music]
bit
I gotta keep you alive buddy
don't let them have this
push them back
this is stupid but we going down
that was pretty stupid
I I I've had no issues now
yesterday in the day before I was in 20
000 Q 20
000. players hey continue Mason we're
going your computer
crazy fight
we about to lose these
ah this [ __ ] is stupid
wow this dude just came in to get me out
of this game
hey man it was the last game relax
you went the whole experience without
having an episode okay you you should
feel very good right now you controlling
your anger issues I just don't like
these stupid ass games that don't
explain why these little [ __ ] ass
things I'm shooting with this big ass
gun have uh bullet sponge like that it's
called balance
I should feel like a freaking immortal
like it's like I'm sitting like ants
it's called balancing Gotta Have balance
oh my God but it takes them two shots
what's wrong
balancing man
I'm gonna balance I'll play Halo
I have arrived
again all right we got this arrest him
no we don't we don't have the service
yo that you did not like me
oh I got killed by the uh the super okay
this game is bad
man
where was
where was my support that whole time to
be fair I was pretty Far Behind Enemy
line so I guess I guess I don't blame
them yeah I'm I I went another Oprah
oh my God
just stop them from taking the objective
that's all that matters
if they just keep on coming and I can't
do nothing to them shooting them don't
work
if
oh my God
I can only pull them back for a couple
seconds I need the other people on the
team to do something
he's almost at the end
yeah
any game that where I can go oh for
seven and again
wow
yeah I think Reaper's change might have
changed I don't know
yeah they kept us in there with that uh
well Diva super
so you uninstall and OverWatch too yeah
I probably won't install it but I ain't
touching this [ __ ] for a while
that's a six uh
I like it
is tranquility
I lost
all right smooth we can get off
OverWatch
when it came out with a new series Sam
librarian Mayhem yeah we can get off
OverWatch movie do you want to play
grounded
foreign
[Music]
sure
no problems Leo uh you know definitely
go uh
go follow smooth on YouTube
go there and give us some support
you know he's uh he's going through it
on OverWatch man he's going through it
let's do it
ground under the ground
grounded
there's this game it's called slaycation
looks good
my cart
it's called what
play cage
it looks like it's like a zombie um
Zombieland games
hopefully it's not janky you know the
the music kind of reminds me of um
stranger things
[Music]
a little bit
[Music]
being
Cog and King are playing this tomorrow
you want to participate
[Music]
are you grounded yeah
participate
because I don't know if so I was gonna
be able to make it he's a busy person he
works a lot
so how are we doing this do I join your
game like
um yeah sure let me see where I'm at
this
[Music]
thank you so I like the soundtrack man I
like the soundtrack
yeah
pretty good little soundtrack man I have
appreciate it
smooth uh just look up kids smooth on
YouTube
follow them on uh on Twitter he has a
lot of uh spicy takes I'm sure you guys
will enjoy
[Music]
so do I join you or what
um I didn't um I just set up the game
Post online game
all right go ahead you guys got me for
about maybe an hour in this and then I
gotta take off
it's only giving me the option for one
person
it's not you yeah it should actually be
live now it should be playing Xboxes to
see the world
there you go I need a squad for this one
I didn't even know how to play the game
tell me if you guys feel like that's too
big
my name's Peter
hence call me Pete
[Music]
all right I picked uh Pete I picked Pete
me and Peter won
Ali who ready for adventure I picked
Pete
[Music]
Pete I'm Pete
[Music]
your screen is bad your camera's mad big
yeah I mean
if you shrinky on a goof yeah I can
shrink it but it's just like this is
grounded I don't really think
there's a lot of real estate that takes
up on like the bottom right of the whole
screen I mean if they feel like I would
lift your screen up like half like to
the point where you could at least see
your um
yeah I could see what you're talking
about
all right so
all right
so I don't even know what we're doing I
don't even know are you is this not even
a base anymore
this is a I have a separate base next to
the uh this campaign yo there is a bunch
of backpacks everywhere
yes a lot of depths
is this your death
I'm never gonna find you man
oh those um oh yeah I forgot I'm all
yeah I'm like
[Music]
yeah can I respond I should be able to
respond back to the base
can't you get like zip lines to move
quicker
I'm pretty sure you can I don't know how
to make them yet
um I'm trying to think uh is
I'm gonna run into a spider you know
do you see my name yeah I'm running
towards you all right
well you're gonna run into something
crazy
yeah this I'm scared
I think if they're way accurate
oh I was supposed to my armor repairs
it's a bunch of water
you can get it
it's crazy how good this game looks
I built a fort in that area got a wooden
cabin now and a grasp one I believe it
he means grass all on my own no Co-op
I feel like these kind of games are best
to call man there's a bunch of bees oh
my God
because of a giant blood-sucking
mosquito is this the worst time to tell
you that I don't like bees
the being on here
I hear the B and it just it's tripping
me oh
what is this it's a wasp
that's a mosquito I think
can it come in the water
yeah mosquitoes like water
no that was that I'm pretty sure that
was a
a B I don't think that was a mosquito it
might have been scared
that [ __ ] scared me
these people don't play
I found a clover
[Music]
three leaf clovers are four leaf flavors
in this
guy is it where am I supposed to go this
is where I get [ __ ] up
how big is this game
Gary I'm in the middle of a tree
I don't even know how to get up to you
[Music]
I think oh there's a spider over here
there's a bunch of spiders over here
I'm good at fighting them especially if
I'm well armored but
okay why don't you enlighten me on how
to get to you
um well
I really can't because
all right
I'm not I don't want no smoke with
spiders man
is there a better way to get to you
um
oh God
this is where we died okay
you're in like a bunch of frogs
[Music]
I don't know what I'm doing how far are
you I'm by this junk
I don't know how you got up there like
you're on like it was a a bunch of rocks
like I can't
what is this
I'm gonna respond that uh I'm responding
at the kid case oh you never mind you
got all the way over there
yeah I just I just don't know
how to get up to that platform that
you're on
uh yeah I'm kind of no clue what that is
uh if you happen to die
um go back I apologize
I know I'm in your territory
is my b
you can get that's larvae just kill him
before it started bobbing
oh that's larvae just kill it before it
starts bothering you
see so I don't be listening to you
I'm responding at the kid case
and I'm glad I got to repair my game
man
recover backpack
look at your Beetle put on your peepers
[Music]
is there a way to
how do you use the peepers
smooth
how do you use them
your hands location marked
that's just I thought it told you like
their health and stuff
yeah you have to hit the trigger on them
or something like that
look at the bottom right of the
controller to tell you
it's a peep creature but it's
oh great
if you'd vomit your Beetle early warning
system has positive contact
yeah all right
so dead
there's nothing I can do that's going to
stop this
I I don't know I don't know
I'm back at the suitcase so if you
respond or respondents YouTube
respond at kid case
[Music]
everything better still be here you
stupid Max you better not have messed
with my stuff
it takes myself I gotta repair some
things
ah yes I love this backpack I Spy
I'll share my word with you so you don't
have to I don't have to be on while you
play
I got to find a way to repair this [ __ ]
uh all right I'm gonna go to uh
it's all there
why is all those backpacks back there
because I had when you die you built
your put backstage and diets I died in
places it's hard to get to so I reset it
I had all my backpacks go straight to
the case
[Music]
oh is there like something you can do to
have that happen
yeah it's it's part of game repair
option
oh you guys got like a little
toss
a little peeper things ain't working huh
let's go
Oh no I got to repair this my armor
thing works
why isn't the Peeper thing working
I got to be doing something wrong maybe
I have to like unlock it by playing the
game more
probably if you got anything to analyze
I would go ahead and analyze it how do
you analyze stuff I went to this uh room
here
wow wow
Okay so
I'll go back to go back and get that
[ __ ] I gotta get I gotta be able to
repair my armor dude so there's no way
I'm going all the way back over there in
regular headphones
I had an acorn armor
what is it
Acorn armor
yeah
I don't know
that's Easter West I might have to take
some of that [ __ ] where did you go
back to the suitcase
I got bow and arrows and everything I
need that I need to get exactly I can't
afford to like this not
I got to be able to repair something
ah yes I love this backpack
I don't even know where you at man I'm
back at the suitcase bro I'm getting
another good game
I have to remember I went to where all
the backpacks are I have to repeat after
I got I got armor that I need to repair
otherwise like left you
got at least repair mine let me see if I
can craft something
questions wise I should be a bit of crap
and craft a bow and arrow for crafting
equip that I entered virtual Explorer
and it made me drop my bow and arrow
hold on let me drop something
get that [ __ ] back
yes babe
uh spicy uh chicken sandwich with the
sauce and a milkshake
[Music]
strawberry
okay okay all right
Addy did you take my bow
damn it put it down I don't know how to
stop shooting and wasting the ammo I
didn't I dropped you some Acorn armor
though but you have to repair it
did you just
you said you wanted it
yeah but you threw it
[Music]
you taught me what
is the acorn chest plate armor right
here but you're gonna have to get the
materials to repair you or unless you
already got it
I don't know how to prepare anything
you press y on the item
whoa what's hitting me stop why are you
doing [ __ ]
uh I need Acorn shell I have no clue who
that is but that's by the oak tree we
can get there together oak tree
I thought we were supposed to stay away
from the oak tree
no I did it's part of the submissions
are there
can't
I feel like you're not respecting the
oak tree it's me
I think I've survived it I got a base
set up there actually
well then let's go
I got I can't I can't go there naked I
need my armor so you want me to go there
naked
here let me
drop these rocks right quick
rocks which I I have um Marvel
what can I do with Marvel
I have an acorn shovel
I need Acorn pieces that's what I really
need is Acorn oh there we go
uh crusted rope
I have a a pebble spear
I got some red ant stuff
you're gonna need that for some armor I
don't have nothing to repair it with
yeah I'm struggling man I'm struggling
are you ready I got a bother
oh hold on man um I gotta I gotta drop
some
[ __ ] on me so I can meet
drop this let me
drop
these goggles I'll come back for them
um and I there I thought where was that
I I don't know that's you're the expert
did you
retrieve all right there's gotta be
something left in what the hell is that
sound
we're gonna have to get something to
drink in a little bit
all right I can repair my maps
or just wear some armor
all right sounds uh what else do I need
so I have uh
it seems
I have
48 Arrow 40 no
53 I believe in all 53 yards everything
better still be here you stupid ants
it's looking like
I can get another
I got 54 arrows
yeah there's a there's a ton of them
now what's these stones for
I dropped it there's a
uh
yes
we can use to make that we make with
them but how you gonna give me stuff you
don't even know what to use
because you I don't know you might have
some of the stuff I don't have to drop
these grass blades or something
like that
and dry
dry little immediate don't need that
I need to grab these stupid ants
upper body I need something so I need
something man
you want me to go out here naked
it's looking like I'm about to go over
here naked too man this is this is rough
let's go though let's go I don't got
along
you don't understand
it's fine we're gonna be fine man YOLO
will be fine
I Believe in Us
oh I need water [ __ ]
all right where you go
I Believe in Us I don't like outside
take a nap yeah I think we should go
tonight
I don't know what that sound is again
that's too early nav that's just some
dude um
those black bugs but I do need a drink
of water before
um I go to bed otherwise I'm gonna wake
up in like
yeah my water is almost there my Hunger
is less than half
my stomach is full I just need something
that
there is
a cup of water
I could probably drink
I shouldn't have to settle for poison
water all right here we go there's some
water right here
I also have a canteen it's in that
backpack
if you need some water there's another
drop right here
yeah definitely water right here are you
behind me
and fall into the water
okay I don't even need to boil it
'll be good we good
all right let's go
I feel conf I feel comfortable with
you want to go out right now or you want
to try if we sleep we're gonna wake up
in the dark
can't we go to sleep again though
if we leave but if we also if we leave
right now we're gonna We can probably
make it to the oak tree okay let's go
then
all right let's go
oh we're
ah did I
did I drop my bow
did you no I needed that
can we can we make another bow
um it should be in your inventory dude
oh no here it is here I don't know why
it de-equipped it so
how do I quit
all right let's go
okay
what's up flying
let's go I feel confident man let's go
if we die though I'm blaming you
where's my BM
thank you I hear something to our left
we gotta get going before it gets dark
okay we're gonna go to the oak tree
power of
heat trees straight ahead
um
they shouldn't say OverWatch anymore
flame you should say grounded no played
OverWatch for like an hour and a half
too switch up following me yeah I'm
right behind
some things trying to attack me though I
don't know what it is
there should be some like
oh God so Mike is this the oak tree
yeah all right so my Hideout was over
there so we can go we should be able to
brush these Walnut shells
found some sap
I'll do right here
oh I don't like that
no if you take a shovel oh [ __ ] that's
it
here take this grub
ticket please
I can't use it right now
um
[ __ ]
I have web fiber is that any good
it will be
um actually you're gonna
let me I thought I got stuff that I
don't [ __ ] need
I'm a bot and grounded Smith that's
ridiculous
I have an acorn shovel though
yeah that's gonna be good that's good to
get the big grubs out of the um Brown
that thing I told you to pick up
where
there's another one over here
do they respawn eventually
but the acorns yeah there's a ton of
them around there but I have um
I just wanna I should be able to
hear Acorn over here yes quit
yes
all right do you want some knee pads
uh attic Acorn knee pads I found another
Acorn though
yeah but no it's here put part of this
gear on unless you have to craft
hold on one second
drop you right here
and just uh equip it like
uh
uh how do I drop it all right here
I just dropped uh some knee pads for you
huh
up
pick up those knee pads that's like
that's a good armor
so far as the highs you're gonna get
until we get uh like a ladybug or um
hurry up man
I'm trying to figure out what to draw
you got some [ __ ] the only thing you
need right now is like grass ant
material and acorns I got a real armor
pulley you need the Rope don't don't get
rid of the roof dandelion
Candy Line oh useful for the where I was
so just in case
uh that's for I think good for band uh
for uh first aid kit he said get rid of
someone said
yeah get rid of your Pebbles and get rid
of your um
and and hurry up and eat that little uh
bug that you got in there this is about
to go expired you got a bug in your
inventory just to eat it because your
your stomach is low
you see that little um how do I eat it
consume why just close your eyes
pounder all right
all right so let's let's grab those knee
pads um if you equip it it's not going
to take up any inventory
why did it go okay okay
uh equipped even a little safer now
you uh did I give you I gave you a chest
plate right how much more Acorn do you
need to craft the chest plate
Acorn chest plate
yeah
I need some Clover leaves I need a uh
uh clove a crude rope
and I need one more Echo shell
all right wait wait for the crew rope go
oh press um L uh LT because you can
probably make it press press Start press
that go into your inventory again
okay you're a little bit behind remember
that
all right and again
over it's not a weapon
I need plant fiber for a crude rope
yeah but you probably have it now
decided kingcraft oh yeah you need I got
I think I have I know I dropped uh yeah
I dropped a lot of that back at the
thing but we can go to sleep and then we
can get all that stuff in the morning
before the spiders come out
but we can go to sleep I got two
sleeping so I was at the sleeping spot I
got is right
over here you following me if you
haven't follow me
or you might want to drink some of this
juice
right here
all right
I got a base set up right
there's another juice over here
huh yeah um
what's that purple orange oh [ __ ] that's
a spider Straight Ahead next to the base
do we kill it purple Aura is the [ __ ]
that I'm not killing that I can't I
can't
can't kill it
I'm just not if you're good with the
arrow I would say yeah
will it come over oh it's coming
directly for us fam yeah I'm going
behind the juice box
yeah and then
once we lose it just run to the base and
go to sleep but I'm gonna be kind of
juice box I'm not playing with that [ __ ]
right now
don't let it see you
I feel like we can kill it if we Arrow
the hell out no no no no no we can't all
right Shadows watch you guys I feel like
that's just scared you speaking
nah because I can beat a spider I can't
beat that spider it's too big if it's
three of us that's one thing three four
of us but if it's just us two and you're
not even confident in a way that you
play this game yet
all right Attic come on I'm about to go
to sleep hurry up I'm going towards the
base follow my light
okay I'm going I'm going
dude I ain't gonna lie I'm a little I'm
a little nervous
I am shaking a little bit
all right
to use
Five Points
all right
damn we gotta get eaten a drink
all right but I can I don't need uh
uh what about the water that's right
here
[Music]
um
I really wouldn't bother with that
because there's actually water spiders
in there there's what
yo yo yo
you ready to fight this thing oh my God
I guess
spider elimination strategy is gonna be
much easier than that
oh it's jumping
it's jumping
I'm sorry I I take it back
I take it back
all right hopefully I get up before
oh he's coming back
my kids killed the spider because they
glitched into the spider eliminations
and my daughter just kept Welling on it
that was rough like a lot
someone help me
and how many seconds
I'm good I'm going for my
where did the spider go
all right so let me switch into
oh where's my book bag where did I die
at I died like missed every arrow oh
there we go I shot him a couple of times
yeah I just picked them
all right I I have a weapon for it if
you if you really trying to fight it I
have a weapon for it I have a couple
weapons for you but I need you need to
be like kind of really efficient with
your with your range your your arrows
because if you hit them with the arrow
I can um all right all right that's fine
I can combat him with this bet all right
I don't have much time anyway so we
might as well go out slate
where'd he go
those wolf spiders don't play
so the spiders in the water
uh there's a special type of spider that
that is in the water it's not like your
traditional spider but you get what kind
of spider it is
where'd you go I'm behind you
okay I don't know where I'm gonna try to
uh I'm gonna just look for moving grass
so
I had to have went this way because we
didn't see it
it's a bunch of acorns here too
it's right here
oh yeah but you got a block with it
I didn't know yeah you didn't tell me
how to block
you by the time you said it was a rap I
was dead
[Music]
I'm coming I'm coming back I'm coming
back
pick me up I'm at 25 seconds because I'm
not I'm not I'm keeping myself
I gotta go for
my stuff
[Music]
where I left you all right I'm coming
I'm coming I'm coming
you gotta get up Max
so I think it's the trigger button
opposite trigger button
to block but you might need a melee
weapon that's the thing oh he's coming
what's his problem with me
why do you see that but
catch might be yeah this is why I can't
handle this type of [ __ ] I can't handle
this type of game bro
that that thing is just
uh
I don't mind that spider being op it's
the other spiders that I run into that I
think is a little bit op like the ones
that are uh behind this fence
I thought I lost you
there's a fence behind this uh
pick me up just pick me up I'm not
because I'm not gonna let him do some or
more damage to my name armor all right
we're going to try one more time
all right then you're gonna try one more
time I need you with a melee weapon and
I need you actually need your fully
armored because you can't
oh my God he didn't give wow
he took all my help yeah
in real life
yeah I think that wolf spider is
definitely a little bit more advanced
especially for me
that little guy is elimination strategy
is going to be much use
on that the little guy's just messing me
up
seconds just pick me up so I can just
like at least go to the
five seconds four seconds
three seconds
two seconds you got you gotta go Max
I'm back in it I gotta go back
my stuff
you know where he's at he's coming he's
coming
for me wow
[Music]
coming for you by the way
all right he's done he's done with me
he's officially deemed me not worth his
time
I'm coming for you
let's get out of here that that spider a
little bit too much for me guys
but let's get these acorns
all right
[Music]
there's like four around here
knock this one out I don't have do you
have a spare thing that you can use to
get it so I can get it
there's another one over here
all right there's another one over here
huh
all right let's get the hell out of here
oh here's a two
damn I can't beat it with that thing
what do you get with the tooth
I don't know
well now remember
oh man that spider
does this thing slowly drop
the juice straw yet we should make a
base around this thing
I did it's down the hall but it's not
like a real like a real Beast yeah we
need a rail base
yeah but with that spider lurking around
he destroyed that [ __ ] we need like
isn't there like defense mechanisms you
can use to keep them away
that's true
maybe we'll come back when we're
stronger
yeah but uh
that so that smoke flare is the story
based content
which uh it's the first uh hedge lab
yeah let's let's not worry about oh
anything dramatic
because I'm not I'm not trying to get
killed
nobody wants it why narcissism
[Music]
over there mosquitoes yeah there's
mosquitoes over there we'll get jacked
up thank you babe someone said the
spiders also have like a public event
where they team up and destroy
everything inside
yeah so like hold up
they they'll have multiple spiders come
after you
yeah like three spiders at a time not
three wolf spiders the other it's like a
spider
below them
it seems a little exciting let's do the
whining I'm not picky
a little excessive
you're throwing the ball now yeah I
don't know where it went to
right here
all right let's
[Music]
I got a craft armor so what hold up
in order for me to make the upper Acorn
chess piece I need uh clo uh Clover
leaves
bro so where's clove release is these
things here Clover leaves yeah
any body
sauce huh
sauce I don't know how you get sauce
right
uh well you didn't make yeah I didn't
know you was talking to someone else
question I'm glad
you're probably gonna be gone for a day
or two do you need any thumbnails made
oh
all right so
I got that now I need the crew bro
I need fiber
I can use it how much do you need
oh I found plant fiber no but I actually
got the look already made how much do
you need
um
Acorn face mask I can't use that yet
how many how much rope do you need for
the uh
three more
all right here you go one two three
all right so
crafter equip
ment I need a workbench Mommy
right here
uh there's right there
[Music]
chest piece
you got it yeah I think
is it did it not equip is it on the
um
where is it
oh here it is
that should keep me safe
okay safe first how much you need to
make the mess
um
workbench
where's the sauce I need
I need a my uh five might
three ropes
you hear me
yeah I might have I don't have to fuzz
in the um all right go get this and I'll
and I'll get it back at like the base
inside storage
okay well then we'll go back
all right let's let's start heading back
you know
[Music]
Disney Channel
your drink is down I can see that is
this the only sauce we got
Dang if you saw a second in the bag
okay
two of those
lemonade yep
all right I need more
um if I believe so and I'm not 100 sure
because I don't keep up with uh
um
I don't keep up with that show
is I think that it is
um
I think about this is on vacation or
something like that and I think that's
the reason they can have it
but I'm I'm unsure 100 so you know
don't hold me
you know you got entire Army in your
inventory and armor set which is one of
the best armors to have I don't know how
to fix any of it
do I need this GrubHub
um grubhard you complete a side question
yes
but um no you don't need it right now
so I can get rid of that if I wanted to
yes right there just to give you a heads
up that white carton is a plate of food
it can expire
oh this
no the um
next to um
yeah chewy but not bad
I need to get more fiber
where did you go
all right I gotta start calling this a
day so let's start making our way back
to the base
all right something to eat
mushrooms
as well
see here
craft
what did him
I didn't realize I can't afford to take
another hips
[Music]
I think I already have a pair of legs
don't I didn't you give me legs for yeah
you're wearing them
unless they're damaged we got beaten off
you
see yeah
um but I need the mask
so I just need the mid fuss now
hold on I think I got some of that
let's pause
how much do you need I got four of them
I think I need five yeah I need five
how much do you have on you no none zero
all right you know use of getting him
giving it to you
remember where the old place is
I'd be on this gate right here is spider
central
I need some water I need some water
slide your spiders around that gate I
need some water like ASAP
do you see any water drips
um
no
because I'm going to pass out
yeah turn around water drips where Dew
drips whatever it's called
there's no lemon crime but you see those
spiders that's spider central
yeah
wait
okay I'm waiting for him I want to smoke
let's go we can be oh he poisoned me
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
okay
[Music]
[Music]
you gotta get up Max
come on come on
[Music]
oh I don't like it
can I get in the water no not those
spiders they won't get annoyed
where you at you went oh you're gonna
get close to the mosquitoes bro
who's that in the water
I don't know
he's in the water
foreign
ER again
um
uh as a weapon that I need to do it I
just spare I usually spare
well
[Music]
all right
that one's too big but we could probably
take it
okay I'm ready
all right
what's that where you wet bro I'm right
here
all right so we're just gonna spike him
to death or what let's go up to the
middle one first
where's the little one okay right here
[Music]
oh [ __ ] he took it
yeah
[Music]
[Music]
oh my God I wish you could crawl it's
kind of [ __ ] that you can't crawl
[Music]
um
[Music]
I can't catch
spotted the big spiders close to me
I mean we can't even take little ass
spiders on
weird I don't know why their health left
is that [ __ ] high
I'm coming for you right now
someone help me
it's not so bad Pete I got you man
they've been
I'm alive
it's the big one get big get in the
water they leave if you get in the water
[Music]
I don't really feel comfortable in this
water either don't be real with you
yeah me neither
all right let's
let's shoot in front of water
you just don't ask it at you
[Music]
okay I thought he was going after you
for a second yeah
foreign
yo he ain't playing let's just go let's
go
am I stuck
let's just go he ain't playing stop
playing with that spider smooth
all right I'm running huh
foreign
oh my God
all right let's get out of here
okay
where is he
are you chasing this I don't know but
let's get out of here
I gotta go let's get back to the to the
mini base the mini mini base you have
wonder what the strongest armor and
ground it is
um it shouldn't be the acorn or whatever
ladybug or hate porn
that's probably not that tall you
probably find things that aren't buggy
tired all right I'll call you tonight
ugh I appreciate everyone coming through
man we had a good stream